samsung has released their latest
iteration of the galaxy z4 and z flip 4
with their latest wearables as well
which includes the galaxy watch 5 and
the galaxy but 2 pro now we had some
time with them during samsung unpacked
so let's give you the lowdown of what's
new in these devices before we begin
here at geek culture we cover plenty of
different topics so the next video might
be different from this if you love the
content so far do consider giving us a
like and subscribe do also feel free to
follow along the chapter markers if you
wish to skip a hit to your preferred
section at any given point with that
let's start off with the galaxy phone 4.
what you're looking at is samsung's
thinnest and lightest fold yet albeit
the same design language as it stands
the phone now weighs in at 263 grams
with a dimension of 155 by 130 by 6.3
millimeters when unfolded what we are
getting here is a 7.6 inch qx ga plus
dynamic amoled display here with the
fault 4 at 120 hertz what's interesting
here is that the fault 4 appears to have
a shorter and wider aspect ratio from
the fault 3 coming in at an expect ratio
of 21.6 by 18 for the main display and
23 by nine for the cover display so you
are definitely getting extra real estate
from both displays now the fold is much
more comfortable with one-handed use
here when folded and the main display it
does give you a more tablet-like
experience now samsung has also
addressed the issue with the crease now
being less prominent than the previous
iteration and having durability tested
over 200 000 times now delving into
hardware the snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 cpu
with adreno 730 graphics is currently at
the forefront of most flagship
smartphones in 2022 and it will be
included in the ford 4 as well the phone
will ship with android 12 alongside a
redesigned ui with split screen mode and
multi-window viewing for improved
productivity there's a new taskbar for
app switching so you'll be able to
hot-seat your favorite apps to the
taskbar for more seamless experience
there's also the flex mode touch pad
which gives you a split screen panel
with controls so say you open up the
camera app the top screen will have the
live feed playing and then the bottom
half will show you the camera controls
and the photo gallery now bear in mind
we have yet to see the full capabilities
of the flex mode touchpad but samsung
says they will roll this feature out
with a slew of native apps and you can
expect a video on that in the coming
weeks so be sure to subscribe and click
the bell to stay updated moving on to
the cameras the ford 4 features a 10
megapixel selfie camera at the front
with an additional 4 megapixel under
display camera when unfolded on the rear
is a triple camera system with a 15
megapixel wide angle camera a 10
megapixel telephoto camera with three
times optical zoom and 30 times space
zoom
and additionally we also have a 12
megapixel ultra white camera which will
provide 23 percent brighter pictures in
low-light conditions of course there is
the new s-pen full edition which is
designed specifically for the fort 3 and
4 4 in mind not to be confused with the
s pen pro which works with other samsung
devices yeah so the s pen fold edition
comes with a retractable pen tip for
more simulated pressure and the fork 44
will not have a dedicated silo or slot
for the s-pen but rather a new case
which will house the s-pen on the side
instead of the hinge now the new fold
also boasts a 4 400 milliamp hour
battery and a 25 watt charger that will
fill up to 50 percent of the battery bar
in just around 30 minutes it will also
come in four colors the classic phantom
black a new signature gray green
colorway beige and an online exclusive
burgundy red when it launches on the 2nd
of september price wise the 4 will
retail for 2 398
for the 256 gigabyte model
2578 for the 512 gigabyte model and
2938 for the one terabyte model with
pre-orders going live now now that we're
finished with the fold let's talk about
the sibling the galaxy flip 4 now you've
got a smaller hinge design slimmer
bezels around a 6.7 inch full hd plus
dynamic amoled display screen and a more
compact body here along with 120 hertz
refresh rate samsung is staying with a
1.9 inch cover screen display and added
gorilla glass victus plus for added
durability on the front and back panel
we are also seeing the snapdragon 8 plus
gen 1 chip here on the z flip 4
accompanied by 8 gigabytes of ram and
storage that comes in 128 256 512
gigabyte variants with 5g and bluetooth
5.3 support
on the rear there's a dual camera array
which will comprise of a 12 megapixel
wide angle camera with optical
stabilization and a 12 megapixel ultra
wide angle camera with the same specs as
its predecessor but now with a 65
brighter pixel sensor
now samsung has also improved the
battery capacity for the z flip 4 making
it a 3 700 milliamp hour battery for
all-day usage
now charging support has been upgraded
as well with samsung offering 25 watt
wired charging and 15 watt wireless
charging now it might not sound like
there's a lot going on for this
iteration of the z flip 4 but the
changes are coming on the software and
feature side with samsung getting better
at developing these softwares and
features for its portable phones now for
example samsung has added more
functionality without opening up the
device in this case the cover screen
display has been revamped to have easy
access to notifications widget control
and quick settings to functions like
wi-fi bluetooth airplay mode and even
utilities like the torchlight mode now
the galaxy z flip 4 will come in four
different color ways graphite pink gold
bora purple and blue samsung is also
rolling out a bespoke edition of the
flip 4 allowing you to customize up to
75 unique color combinations by changing
the colors of the front panel frame and
hinge and the back pedal as for prices
the galaxy flip 4 is set to cost 1 398
1498 and 1748
for the 128 256
and 512 gigabyte models respectively now
the photobulls aren't the only ones with
upgrades with samsung putting their
attention towards their wearables lineup
the galaxy watch 5 is a significant
offering of health upgrades and design
options compared to their earlier models
the new smartwatch will come in two
variants a sportier one with a 40
millimeter watch face and a slightly
bigger
millimeter watch face then there's also
the 45 millimeter watch 5 pro a new
addition that will replace the
traditional classic model with a
titanium frame and a sapphire glass
protecting the display
powered by wear os the galaxy watch 5
lineup boasts features revolving around
new health and fitness tracking
technology for the outdoor enthusiasts
now samsung has also added more hardware
to the watch 5 with a bioactive sensor
of the heart rate sensor ecg ekg sensor
and so much more for a complete
end-to-end experience in fact you can
now track your body composition and
real-time recovery tracking after a
workout which i personally feel it's
pretty awesome to have now the galaxy
watch 5 has also been optimized to last
longer it's running on a bigger 590
milliamp hour battery with 30 faster
charging now the 40 millimeter galaxy
watch 5 will set you back 448 for the
bluetooth model and 548 dollars for the
bluetooth and lte version with the 44 mm
iteration coming in at 498
and 598 respectively the pro variant
meanwhile retails for 698 dollars for
the bluetooth model and 798 dollars for
the lte version last but not least we
have the galaxy but pro 2.
you've got a rounder more aerodynamic
shape here from the base design and i've
tried it on and it's very very light and
very very comfortable the duo driver
design has been carried over but the new
earbuds will now feature a smaller 5.3
millimeter tweeter to complement the
smaller 10 millimeter woofer on each
earbud there is also ipx7 water
resistance so if you are sweating in the
gym or getting caught in the rain you
won't have to worry about raining them a
new feature for the butts pro 2 is
support for 24 bit audio a higher
resolution standard than the typical 16
bit or lower standard you get from
streaming services now you would need an
audio player compatible with 24-bit
music or 24-bit streaming service like
tidal or spotify hi-fi in these cases to
benefit from this feature but it should
be an appealing addition for audiophiles
on top of that there is 360 spatial
audio with direct multi-channel support
using adobe hit tracking technology
which seems pretty cool following the
likes of sony's 360 reality audio format
found in their xm model headphones and
i'm interested at how the butts pro 2
will fare anc is another upgrade over
its last iteration with the earbuds now
delivering advanced intelligent enc and
improved noise cancellation which is
said to cut ambient noise by 33 decibels
now similarly to its other releases
samsung has also improved the battery
performance here the earbuds will run
for up to a total of 8 hours with anc
turned off and up to 5 hours with anc
turned on and a total play time of 29
hours with the charging case with anc
turned off
now you get standard usb type c port for
wide charging and unfortunately there
will not be any wireless charging
support for the galaxy but 2 pro now
these earbuds will set you back 328 at
launch and will be available in graphite
white and bora purple now 328 is pretty
much the same price that samsung charged
for the first iteration of the galaxy
but pro so it's definitely something you
want to consider
now that covers our hands-on experience
at samsung unpacked which phone are you
going for team flip or team fold which
color are you gonna get do let us know
down in the comments below we will have
more news and videos in the coming weeks
so do subscribe to the channel and click
the bell icon in the meantime do check
out other reviews right here
yeah
click on it click
click
yes